on the island of Bali signs of
spirituality are everywhere to be seen
there are at least twenty thousand
public temples and most have rituals
that are distinct from those of any
other but in the ancient village of kisi
believers take part in a right that
people elsewhere might consider taboo
tomorrow a goose Sue and Tara will rest
his faith on the point of a knife once
every Balinese year the people of his
village appealed to their gods during a
rite called Bhangra baingan during
pinger bangla devotees offer their
bodies to the will of the gods who are
said to control the knife in return they
hope the gods will grant them continued
prosperity in the upcoming year although
Indonesia is the world's most populous
Muslim nation in Bali the dominant
religion blends imported Hinduism with
local belief in spirits the spirit world
infuses daily life
auguste may have gotten his religious
conviction from his father on ik on ik
works carving the elaborate cremation
towers that typify Balinese funerals but
he also serves as a priest in the
upcoming ceremony as the priest
it is onyx responsibility to wear the
mask of wrong doe the widow which of
death
the wrong damask will be purified to
gain consciousness the Balinese believe
that ceremonial masks act like lightning
rods for the gods they hold enormous
cosmic energy for good or evil when the
God enters into them it is the morning
of the festival all goose and other
members of his extended family set off
in a regal procession but they are not
alone column after column of devotees
from other family compounds and even
other villages fill the streets some of
the other groups have brought wrong to
masks of their own others arrive
accompanied by abiram a mythical beast
whose magic is believed to protect
villages from harm the gods begin to
arrive
[Music]
on his himself over kuranda all around
other living gods cease breathing bodies
a spirit and a zombies one believer
after another is helped through the
ceremonial gate knives are raised and
ready then August impales the knife
against his chest it is the job of his
keeper to restrain him all around him
others take the same dead
only rarely does the blade actually
enter the body but the attempted
sacrifice is a clear sign of the God's
presence
finally weary in days
they are helped back through the gate
slowly the gods depart the bodies of the
faithful for August his belief in the
gods has delivered and safely
[Music]